so the two sides of privatization but
what's the best path for greece to take
in its current situation let's turn
again to alexander kritikos from the
german institute for economic research
in berlin
you're half greek half german
is greece selling out
no i don't think so
privatization has two issues it's on the
one point is selling something and
selling something out of public hands
and the other thing is
making private
companies allowing them to make things
more efficient and this is what we can
see with the greek harbor the public
side is tremendously inefficiently
working and the private size side works
very efficiently and adds to the greek
economy and this may be one of those
parts where we can see that greece can
have the opportunity to grow in the
future okay but that future seems to be
very far off right now because the
problem is of course that even if there
is another bailout right now and even if
they sell the port it won't be enough
for the greek economy to get back on
track simply because of its enormous
debt we can see it here take the
international monetary fund greece
managed to gain some breathing space
this month by postponing its debt
repayment but it will have to pay
eventually almost 4 billion euros
between july and december
and then of course it also owes even
more to the european central bank a
whopping three and a half billion euros
are due in july another 3.2 billion in
august how is this supposed to work
well it will only work indeed when the
second program will be paid off the
remaining seven billion euros will be
paid that just about covers this this
covers this exactly and this would cover
so to say this year's step and we would
see it kind of a debt restructuring but
the main point is i think greece will
find only out of this crisis if they go
on with reforms those reforms they
didn't do so far in particular around
product markets are about opening new
markets as long as this is not started
we will not see greece come out of out
of this situation but if this is so
obvious why don't they do it
well there are many vested interests in
greece and
this is the problem we will need to see
a government who is not depending on
these kind of vested interests and is
trying to do
this kind of of reforms we haven't seen
for five years all right
yeah it's it's a long process uh surely
and it'll be interesting thank you very
much uh for giving us your take on that
story alexander critic chris thank you